[Music]
okay everyone I'm so excited because I'm
joined by Marielle John and Aaliyah
talking all about the watchful eye which
is on freeform and Hulu how you guys
doing today pretty good hey we're good
how are you good I'm excited to talk to
you guys absolutely love the show and
Mario what I really love about this show
is one moment it feels like you got
these mystery detective scenes happening
and then there's like these horror
sequences that are great what did you
have more fun filming on set oh
these scenes where I was alone you know
filming these Thriller sequences with
these horror aspects were probably the
most challenging because you know a lot
of what we do is uh edit it in post and
so a lot of the times you're reacting to
things and sounds and
people that aren't there and so that
takes a lot of imagination and it's also
a technical thing and so that was really
challenging because I'd never done a
thriller before
and a lot of it has to do with the set
and the camera and the movement and so I
think that was something that I learned
so much about and I at the same time was
really challenging but what was
incredible was working with those sets
and the interior of the gray born and
just kind of like the overall eeriness
of the sets that we got to work with I
think that uh the art Department did
such an incredible job in really
creating
this
character that is the gray born so that
was that was really really fun
yeah and that's cool you mentioned I did
not know it was your first Thrillers
doesn't seem like you do such a good job
and it's exciting because I have people
to see those sequences really good stuff
and then
John Scott will do anything to get this
Ruby why do you think he's so hell-bent
on wanting the fortune that comes with
it how are you reading that well I think
wanting a fortune I think we can all
understand you know money money
um so there's that there's some other
um behind the scenes motivations to get
uh
I guess uncovered as the series goes on
that you'll find out about so it's not
just the money aspect driving him
there's some revenge and some other kind
of family stuff going on but you gotta
you gotta watch into the series a few
more episodes to find out about that no
that's a good answer and good hook
because like yeah that's what I love
about the character Scotty so layered
and a lot of mysteries to him so and you
do a great job at it and then
um Aaliyah it feels like you and
Marielle just like have so much fun
together in your scenes did you guys gel
from the start because it shows on
screen but did you guys like click right
away when you guys start working
together yes
[Laughter]
you know this is our job so uh you know
just as just as you have work mates and
colleagues in any other situation
sometimes it just it remains a
professional relationship but
immediately upon meeting Mariella's
already so enamored by her
um and and felt so deeply for her our
first conversation was so deep and very
deep it was so deep and I think just
from there on it just
developed so effortlessly and I'm so
happy that that translates to screen uh
you know I think Jenny and Elena's
relationship is is much more complicated
uh because they are blaring the line
between or between professional and
personal relationship
um and I think just as Jenny gets closer
to Elena
uh things are just gonna get much much
trickier uh for the two of them to
navigate together
yeah and I'm glad to hear that you had
just as fun doing as it looks and it's
gonna be interesting people to see
because it's a really good relationship
on the show and I think that's something
that wants me to keep coming back to it
now
um Mario I absolutely love I'm jealous
that you have one blue eye and one brown
eye and I I love that the show mentions
it though and Embraces it so in your
career overall with that have you felt
like it's given you a kind of an edge
and kind of embracing that
actually no I've actually had projects
in the past where people have suggested
that I put on a contact lens to kind of
like make it the same color I I had a
co-star once that said that it was too
distracting to look at me wow yeah so
it's actually been kind of the opposite
and what's so great about that scene and
I'm glad that you pointed that out is
that
um
actually that was a conversation that I
had with our showrunner Emily when we
were talking about my eyes and they were
like yeah it's just like David Bowie and
I was like well actually David Bowie got
punched over a girl and that affected
his cornea and then I come to find out
that they put that in the script and it
was kind of like a wink wink nah nod
literally a wink
um and that was really cool and I think
you know it is something that is very
specific about me I remember growing up
I thought I was like very weird because
I saw people with the same colored eyes
but I loved it I I love it I always say
I'm like a mutant you know y'all yeah I
I think that's so cool and that you
embrace it and I'm actually jealous of
it so really cool and uh yeah you can
buy them whenever you want thank you
yeah I'm gonna get another contact just
to get with that yeah I got one blue so
that's a start
um so John question for you are you a
watch on live free form type of guy or
watch next day on Hulu type of guy oh
I'm definitely next day on Hulu kind of
person
it's it's hard for me to keep track of
time and to sit down at a specific I
guess it depends on the time it doesn't
it's not going to air until 10 so that's
late enough that I'm I'll be winding
down by then but I so I could watch it
but I've definitely become spoiled with
the on-demand aspect of streaming yeah
what do you mean 10 is way past your
bedtime John there is that but I don't
want to go into that but well you know
it depends I guess on if if you're on
the west coast and you can stream East
Coast then you could watch it three
hours early mm-hmm and I'll probably get
some central time I can watch the East
Coast stream so I'll get it at nine
which is nice right in time for bed yeah
I love that and I like you got all
figured out too and yeah that's what's
really cool I like that there's both
options for this show and then my last
question is for Aaliyah when you just
read this script what was it about your
character that you wanted to make sure
you like got down right like what spoke
to you about the character that you want
to make sure that like you presented
I wanted to make sure that I mean at
least in in the audience's perspective
that uh every part of Jenny feels real
feels true and feels honest uh that way
you never know what's coming next I'm
kidding um but just just because I you
know I wanted her to be someone that
everyone can relate to and take a piece
of her or see a part of them themselves
in and I and I think characters like
that really help anger shows and help uh
people feel very connected
yeah for sure and you totally nail it
and bring that to the screen and I'm
excited for everybody to watch the show
so you can watch the watchful eye on
freeform and next day on Hulu thank you
guys so much for joining me today and
hope to talk to you in the future thank
you thank you thank you for your time